[Musique]
archives de la campagne présidentielle
de 74 avait alors 18 ans quand un
candidat
iconoclaste lui aussi sonne alarme
[Musique]
et vous savez ce qui va se passer eh
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
moquera à lundi je vous dis au revoir et
j'espère vous revoir pour vous expliquer
notre projet global d'avenir merci mes
amis tôt
rené dumont premier candidat écologiste
à l'élection présidentielle
vous en avez le souvenir jean lassalle
parfaitement et je trouve que c'est une
des images cultes de l'ina si j'ai vu et
revu à plusieurs reprises
permettez moi de me distinguer toutefois
un peu de lui parce que bien sûr je je
je je vois ce sommet international mais
je n'ai jamais eu par rapport à ça un
caractère aussi
définitif est désespérée peut-être parce
que j'avais lu la bible comme j'ai lu le
capital ou
et dans la bible
est un passage où il est question du
grenelle et le guen là ça veut dire la
bande verte à l'anglais joe cole qui
n'est jamais fait laminer mais plutôt
l'espagnol qu'on vous l'avez rappelé il
semblerait que le guen l'un s'était pas
que là était une bande ou des cavaliers
se déplacer à bride abattue dans des
nuages de poussière je trouve que
aujourd'hui on manque peut être un peu
trop de climatologues j'en ai suivi un
certain nombre pour démontrer que sur
des périodes courtes les climats en
beaucoup le climat a beaucoup changé
mais moins au lieu de me suicider ou de
m tel père tel stress dans la vie
demande déjà assez
préoccupés par tous je préférerais qu'on
met 1 5% à la recherche fondamentale et
recherche appliquée pour trouver au plus
vite l'énergie de demain je crois
qu'elle sera solaire comme le forum
comme le laboratoire de forum à
perpignan ou alors l'énergie des marées
mélenchon qui est le candidat le plus
expérimenté avec moi en parle lui aussi
vous imaginez que nous allons 11
millions de kilomètres carrés grâce
à nos côtes la chine ne fait que 8
millions de kilomètres carrés est ce que
vous voyez l'espace que nous avons pour
essayer de voir ce fait pas quelque
chose entre avec la différence thermique
qu'il existe entre la surface des flots
et celle qui lie à 2000 mètres de saut
je veux que la france se dote et soit la
première à trouver l'énergie de demain
totalement renouvelable si je vous ai
bien entendu jean lassalle vous vous
contester l'idée que la terre se
réchauffe sous l'effet des activités
humaines en tout cas vous partager
l'idée qu'il y a des des cycles de
réchauffement et de refroidissement qui
sont indépendants de de l'activité
humaine sur la terre
j'écoutais je ne peux pas contester
parce que je ne suis pas assez
je vois un chevronné en la matière pour
ça il y ait aucun des signes et les
images que vous montrez le
le pouce je suis président des
populations des montagnes du monde je
vois à travers les montagnes
effectivement ne siègent que les glacis
mais bien d'autres choses changer mais
en tout cas si tel est le cas on se
trompe totalement d'adressent en
accusant les hommes et les femmes sont
obligées de se servir de leurs moteurs
diesel dans leurs campagnes parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix
[Musique]